hi there Steve Kaufman here and today  you know I got my Champion t-shirt on  Sundays you know it's funny you feel  like a champion because you did  something that you succeeded at and you  feel great some little thing and you're  in a good mood today I'm in a good mood  and I want to talk about immersion some  people think immersion is the secret to  language learning success be careful  little kids when they're five years old  they get together with friends in the  new language they get a ton of input  they don't worry what they sound like  they don't worry about mistakes and so  they learn through immersion adults need  a more specific plan eighty percent  input but you still need 20 on the bits  and pieces the details you want more  information go to the linguist.com for  my 10 secrets to language learning and  be careful of that word immersion it's  not a golden solution to every situation  bye for now